what we're going to do today over here
we're going to look at this this issue
of happiness again it's been a week
since we met
it could be good to do a little bit of
going back over section 2 of
utilitarianism
and going a little bit more into detail
about some of the themes that he brought
up so this will
both you know be a refresher and we're
going to go deeper into it
then we're going to talk about
how mill treats duty
virtue wealth these things that we saw
on other moral theories remember
virtue ethics virtue is key
wealth
is just a means to an end pleasure it's
just something that comes from virtue's
activity if you make it into an end if
you get some problems
duty actually comes from virtue
deontology is going to make duty the
central prime motivator and mill is
actually in part responding to cons when
he's writing about that
one of the things you notice is that
moral theories actually address each
other so there was a reason why plato
brought up
a couple different positions before he
went into his own there was a reason why
aristotle discussed a bunch of different
ideas of happiness
there's a reason why hobbs was trying to
sweep everybody else away
it's because there's other memorable
theories out there if you want your own
to get good hearing you have to show why
it's the best
you can't just go out and say here's my
idea
other people had ideas before you so you
actually have to address their ideas so
that's what mill is going to do
then we're going to talk about how we
would apply this to three sort of big
issues you know oftentimes in ethics
classes they spend a lot of time
focusing on what they call applied
issues so we're actually going to do a
bit of that today and we're going to
look at food and hunger which
utilitarians have written quite a bit
about punishment the utilitarian
conception of punishment actually
radically changed our legal system
and our criminal justice system and then
finally the thorny issue of abortion
so
let's look first at
this idea of happiness again
this is a quote from the fourth part of
utilitarianism
but it applies really well to the second
and
mill is asking can you actually prove
that
this is the best moral theory can you
prove that that there's
a reason why we want to favor the
general happiness he says well in a way
now
because it's so basic
he thinks
that it's not susceptible uh the kind of
proof that we would we would like to
have in some cases he says no reason can
be given why the general happiness is
desirable except
accept the fact that each person desires
his own happiness
as far as he thinks it's attainable and
then he goes on and he says but this is
a fact
each person does desire their own
happiness
he says we can take this as a given
about human nature
and if you think about yourself
who here doesn't want to be happy
anybody
anybody want to be miserable
you do
i mean
sometimes people will say yeah i do
because you know i enjoy being miserable
well then that's your conception of
happiness apparently right a masochist
is made happy by
feeling pain um
there's an old joke actually you know
you guys are familiar with the concepts
of masochist and sadist right so you
just like some lifting pain
and then
the person who says hurt me hurt me and
the sadist is the person who says no
because you know that
screws up somebody else's happiness
um
people who
put their conception of happiness say in
doing their duty and they say i don't
care if i'm happy i just want to do what
i'm supposed to do i want to follow the
rules i want to
do
what you know i'm obliged to
well that's what makes them happy right
that that's one way to respond to that
we're going to look at that a little bit
more closely
each person does in fact desire their
own happiness
here mill is actually agreeing with
aristotle with plato with hobbs with all
the other people that we've looked at
this semester thomas aquinas right
so can you get from the fact that each
of us desires our own happiness to
why the general happiness is desirable
that's kind of a leap isn't it
do you necessarily care what other
people
feel experience
what their outcomes are
if you are seeking your own happiness
what if you are a sadist
what would your happiness be like
making someone else miserable yeah
i mean that would be a very
outlier case right you know that
wouldn't be
the exception
i mean that would that would be the
exception that wouldn't be the rule
but they don't seem to be concerned with
the general happiness
um who else could you think of is
doesn't seem to be particularly
concerned with the general happiness
what's that echoists
egoists egoists yeah anybody who could
anybody who has
an egoist moral perspective
says
i want to get what i want and screw
everybody else if they have if their
interests happen to coincide with my own
or to further my own well that's great
and i'm happy to help them out then but
if they get in my way look out
so an egoist doesn't seem to be very
concerned with the general happiness
and i suppose that would cover pretty
much we could use that to cover
all the sort of individual cases we
might come across
there's actually
a
interesting problem that comes up
whenever you have a group situation it's
called free rider
problem
maybe some of you have experienced this
when you do group exercises or if you
get group grades
one of the reasons why the better
students usually don't like to do group
work
is because
what happens
the majority seem to do do a lot of work
and there's one person that just doesn't
really do
yeah
and you know it's kind of tough
especially we give you guys a lot of
group work
as students
and i think sometimes we don't give you
enough advice on how to be tough on each
other and
say hey you got to do your fair share
um that's an egoist
that's an example of an egoist
perspective right the person who says
well
you know all these other people are
doing the work i can get the credit
i don't really have to do much here i'll
just pretend like i don't know what i'm
talking about
one of the ways to actually get out of
work as you're going to find as you get
older is just be bad at it
people won't ask you to do it you don't
want to do the dishes anymore
start breaking dishes and then people
won't ask you to do it right
but that would not be
living out for the general happiness
mill
says that this is a fact
that everybody does desire their own
happiness
so we not only have all the proof there
could be for such a proposition and all
the proof that could possibly be
demanded that happiness is a good that
each person's happiness isn't good to
that person okay
therefore that gentle happiness is a
good to the aggregate of all persons
what is the general happiness that's
when we put everybody's happiness all
together
and mill seems to be saying something
like well if we were thinking things
through clearly
then we would see that we're happier
when other people are happier
and again you know could could say to
say i'm perfectly happy
when other people are miserable
the
mill actually knew of the guy that we
have
named
sadism after the marquis assad who wrote
a lot of books in which people are the
whole point of them is is not to make
people reading them miserable but the
whole point of the books themselves are
all these different ways in which people
can be
tortured raped abused
um mentally you know put in mental
anguish over over these sort of things
and the fact that the other characters
are deriving pleasure from us
that's where we get the word sadism
maybe that can't be satisfactorily
responded to the milk can probably talk
to
most people
and so that's what we're going to look
at
we have to think also
what is okay so the general happiness
my job
is is the aggregate of individual
happiness right
what is individual happiness
if you have to get one word for a
utilitarian what is it
i think just back to bentham
mankind has two masters
yeah
pleasure very good
um
and that seems really simple and
straightforward right but like we looked
at last class
there's different kinds of pleasures
aren't there
some pleasures are not only
quantitatively better
like you know if you give me
three
let's see my my favorite candy bar that
i routinely
would get i mean there are some really
really good candy bars but i don't
usually get those it would be a
whatchamacallit one watching my college
is that as good as three what you would
call it
pick whatever candy bar you like or
treat or dessert
no three is better than one right but
that's quantitatively better
um
what would go beyond that
reading mill reading learning something
in the process that's better than what
you would call it and it's not better
because it's worth three watching
mccallough or 10 watching mccallis it's
qualitatively better it's at a higher
level
greater pleasure qualitatively
the richer more fine pleasure than that
um eating a really fine meal
i mean let's think in terms of fast food
what are your favorite fast food places
because i know all of us do eat fast
food every once in a while
what are your guilty pleasures
is it mcdonald's is it burger king is it
taco bell is it what's your i like
burger
i prefer burger king to mcdonald's
myself
but
i noticed when i stopped eating burger
king quite so much and i started cooking
for myself i didn't like it quite so
so much as i used to
once you start eating good food
things that are qualitatively
better
the the other pleasures start to pay
over comparison don't they
i could probably live without burger
king
the rest of my life
it wouldn't be any great loss
in part because i'm i'm eating better
food
food that i cook or my fiance cooks or
go to a nice restaurant or
go to somebody's house or they're having
a dinner party and they have something
good for you that's a different thing
the same thing can go for music right
how many of you have had your musical
taste changed since high school
none of you only only one of you well
you're older than the other students
maybe maybe this is going to take a
while but your musical tastes actually
will change
and you may you know come back to the
stuff that you really liked in high
school
i actually did after about 30 no about
20 years
but i was listening to it at a different
level at that point
why would your taste change
what do you think happens to you
and the
music changes and then i don't know for
me everything got repetitive
so then i'd
have to kind of look for something
different
that's that's a good
that's a good feature to look at when
you're talking about lower order
pleasures
after a while they do get repetitive
think about
going out you know the first first
couple times you go out and you're young
it's really fun
and you know everything's a big
adventure but you can get sick of that
can't you
or the first
time you hear
whatever kind of music it is that you
really like
um the first time you heard it i know
the second time that you heard it it was
it might have been like a you know a
revelation to you wow this is this is
out there the world has this
sort of pleasure in it
but then after about you know 10 years
of listening to that stuff
it
tends to become kind of repetitive
same thing can be said for tv shows
um
food
i mean you know actually burger king and
mcdonald's they they go out of their way
to try to make one burger taste almost
the same as another
that's their quality control so it
should get competitive if it doesn't
either you know you've got
miraculous taste buds or
you're getting really bad burgers
let's think again about
pleasures
and what a happy life is like
mill says
according to the greatest happiness
principles as i've explained
the ultimate end for the sake of which
all of the things are desirable what
we're shooting for what we're trying to
govern our life by is an existence as
free as possible from pain that sounds
pretty good right you don't want to have
pain in your life
you've all experienced some pain some
physical some psychological
some of you experience more pain than
others
there are qualitatively worse pains
we talked about those
and as rich as possible in enjoyment
so what is this richness like he says
this means rich in quantity and quality
so a life that is only rich in pleasures
that have
a lot of quantity
there's a lot of different pleasures a
lot of instances but don't have quality
is not a very enjoyable life
this is the kind of life that quite a
few people actually still live today
the lower pleasures
are not truly satisfying for a human
being
the only way in which they become truly
satisfying for a human being is when
that human being's
faculties become dull
when they become used to only
enjoying those lower pleasures think
about reading
some people enjoy reading other people
don't
the best predictor actually for figuring
out whether a child is going to enjoy
reading do they see their parents
actually reading for enjoyment
if they do they understand hey there's
something to this
if they actually talk with the children
about what do you actually
learn from this book what do you find
enjoyable about it that that even
makes it more likely the child will
enjoy reading um and all of us get
introduced to a lot of reading
if we don't go to bad
public school systems
in school right you have to do a lot of
reading and read summer books sometimes
and hopefully you found something that
you liked
and if you did
you probably had to work at it at first
right
there's a lot of great books that are
not easy to read right off the bat
but they will yield you pleasure if you
work at them
just like exercise you know if you if
you decide i want to you know play
football i want to play soccer if ms
garnett was here i don't play basketball
you don't just start out great at it do
you
how many how many
how many hours do you think you guys
have put in doing drills
would you say
including high school
it's got to be in the thousands right is
it maybe in the tens of thousands do you
think
what was what was the whole point of
that
now you actually have a sort of facility
with your body
that lets you enjoy what i hope i hope
all of you who are student athletes
actually still enjoy the game right
that you're doing it's not just work
that would be kind of awful wouldn't it
well reading is like that too and
reading is a a highly refined pleasure
mill tends to dissociate the body and
the mind
i'm not sure that there couldn't be
physical pleasures that wouldn't also be
higher pleasures that you would but you
would have to train yourself to be able
to enjoy that you have to
put yourself at a certain level in order
to
to enjoy it
so he says
rich in quantity and quality the test of
quality how do you test
what you know what pleasures are in fact
higher in quality
the preferences of those who are best
equipped to make the comparison you need
some sort of ideal judge
so if you start out and you pick up a
great work of literature say dostoyevsky
is the brothers karamazov and you start
reading it back in you know grade school
you say
this is really boring
i don't learn about these russian
peasants and what they're doing and
people being drunk and killing each
other that's that's dull
you know i'd rather read the sports page
or the comics or whatever because i'm
familiar with that
you wouldn't be an ideal judge
you wouldn't be
yet at the the point where you could say
you know i have actually experienced
that
and i know it's not for me
um mill tends to think that if you do
fully experience it you will find that
you know say the brothers karamazov to
be up here and say danielle steele to be
down here
but
here's a possibility you could actually
thoroughly
plumb the depths of that pleasure and
then say
just not for me
just like for instance
if you ask me about different musical
genres
some of them i can tell you a lot about
i can say why i like this particular
song or this particular piece and what's
going on i'm sort of a
refined critic when it comes to those
others
i really don't know at all
and i i'm not a good judge about at all
some of them i've actually just found
out about recently
what kind of music is that
and then others i don't like
and i know why i don't like them
and i've given them a chance
and i still just don't like them
and i think you guys can probably relate
to that there are some
qualitatively higher pleasures that
you've tried out
and they just weren't for you right that
doesn't mean that the next person down
down the road can't appreciate them that
doesn't mean that you can't say yeah you
know if one could appreciate this
this would be a higher pleasure
it just means
for you
now what does he say is needed for this
so those best equipped to make the
comparison
equipped by
he says two things
the range of their experience
and
their habits of self-consciousness and
self-observation
so i'm actually going to put this on so
to determine where
pleasures you need experience
and you also need
habits
of
self-consciousness
and
self-observation
okay
so let's say you wanted to acquire these
things
odds are you actually have to sum to
some extent okay
because you guys are on average
somewhere between 20 and 22 years old
so you've actually got quite a bit of
experience do you have more experience
ahead of you
can you think of anything that you guys
haven't yet experienced that you think
you would like to try it out to see if
it's as good as people
say it is
i hope so
because those are what you're striving
for right
what do you want
out of life to get to
try out as it were from the inside
rather than just from the outside
looking at yeah you could say like a lot
of traveling but if you want to go to a
place yeah
that's
that's a great example you guys have all
heard oh travel's so great
how many of you have
traveled a lot
say outside of the united states
oh actually quite a few of you okay so
those of you who have
you have the requisite experience to
judge you know what would be a good
place to go to
should you go to say just go to disney
world over and over and over again some
people would be getting that
but maybe you'd want to go to i don't
know paris and actually
see the the louvre and you know if you
find out that's not for you after you
try it out
then that would be uh good to know but
you won't know until you actually
try it out later and i suppose you could
just get a book and look through it oh
those are the paintings is that the same
thing as going to the museum
not really
um when i when i was in paris i didn't
vote because they just did a bombing and
there was a gigantic line outside so i
just sort of wandered around the town
and i found my way into a place called
la rangeri
and you've all seen claude monet's water
lilies you're all familiar with them you
can get prince at you know target or
stuff like that it's all that you know
impressionist stuff and it's very
colorful and all that and you can get
you know nice print about this big by
this big
um
well what i didn't realize is that
laurangeri is actually these these four
gigantic
circles where the walls are
about you know 12 feet high
and the circles are about
five times the size of this room
and claude monet's water lilies are
actually painted there's four of four
paintings
the entire
length of the room
you wouldn't guess that from looking at
the prints because the prints only give
you like one tiny portion of it i guess
they're sort of like the best hits
the experience of actually being in
there
and taking in that artwork that way
that's something different
that is hard to convey through through
words i think
i mean maybe we maybe with computer
generated stuff now we can we can do
that for you
but there's a lot of things that you
need to experience travel
anything else that you
kind of looking forward to that you've
heard is
great
or at least could be great
you haven't experienced that
yeah yeah um
are any of you married right now
no okay so
um
that that can be a great thing
it can also be a source of a lot of
misery as you find out in some sitcoms
and novels and stuff like that but it
can also be a great source of
pleasures and
there
we talked about this before there are
qualitatively higher pleasures that can
come with that um one reason to get
married is to have sex right i mean if
you
if you're not having sex with the person
that you marry
there's something that got mistaken
somewhere along the line right because
that that's one of the main purposes of
marriage
and
um
you could have sex with you don't have
to actually be married to sex we all
know this you can go out and find
somebody at a bar or
you know do it ad online or something
like that
but and that brings pleasure right but
that's
perhaps a lower type of pleasure than
the pleasure that comes with the
intimacy sharing a life
with somebody for years and years
that's one reason why people stay
married
i mean if it was only about sexual
pleasure
at you know the sort of basic level i
don't think very many people would stay
married for more than two or three years
because human beings tend to get a
little bit you know tired of each other
that way but there is a higher pleasure
that comes with that mill would say of
intimacy
and some of you may have experienced
that maybe you've been in a long-term
relationship i don't know
but
i think that's probably
you know ahead for most of you
and it would be difficult for you to say
whether that really is a higher pleasure
until you've experienced it so what you
have to do is rely on people who you
trust
who have experienced that
experience by itself isn't enough though
it also requires these habits of
self-consciousness and self-observation
we actually have to like sit back every
once in a while and think about these
things
and you don't have to necessarily do it
on your own this is something that men
and women often tend to do
often apart from each other
in their discussions
we don't often think of uh you know we
often think of women going off and
discussing all sorts of things men do
that too
they often do it in in much more you
know comedic ways but
part of what they're doing is they're
comparing things
mill would say that that's part of the
good life
being able to think your way
through these things
and so uh
he also tells us a few other things
about happiness he says
if you want to have a satisfied life
there's two main constituents and then
he says there's two main requirements of
patterns the two main constituents are
tranquility and excitement and
tranquility means having some
time of actual rest and you guys you
know just went on thanksgiving i'm
imagining that
you didn't spend most of your time
just
doing work i hope you
took a break
you relaxed
maybe being with your family is not
always relaxing but you know maybe
that's part of the excitement part
um
but you do need to have some relaxation
in order to be happy
you also do need some excitement some
things that give you a charge
so what stands in the way of this
mill says there's two main things that
actually
stand in the way of it one is
selfishness
you might think well the selfish person
they're gonna seek out as much
excitement as possible or when they seek
out relaxation they're not going to care
who
gets involved in
actually selfishness tends to stand in
the way of genuine
relaxation or genuine excitement
it tends to produce
some characteristics that we don't want
the other thing is
what he calls uh cultivation
mental cultivation
and
what do you think he means by this
because you've done some of this
my hope for you is that you'll you'll
continue to do this
throughout your life
what does mental cultivation mean
doing crosswords like changing like your
perspective on the way these are it
could be i mean
if your perspective was more or less
right from the beginning it could just
be deepening your perspective or be
adding things to it but yeah if you you
know if you come into college
did any of you know everything before
you came to college you'd get your life
completely
worked out and
you know you didn't need to learn
anything from anybody because if you did
then you don't need to go to college
right
you still need to pay for it
you need to you need the the degree
that's why you don't embarrass one you
don't even pay that much for it go to go
to a state school you know
the reason why people go to college
hopefully is they want to have
the college experience right and it
includes a lot of different components
and not all of them are academic
right
um if it was maybe you could just do
stuff online
or just spend all your time at the
library
you're learning you're widening your
of experience you are engaging in mental
cultivation even doing athletes
if you're doing it in the right ways is
mental cultivation
you can ask the athletes it does take
some great presence in mind to be able
to to memorize plays
or figure out what good strategies are
right
so let's think about this a little bit
more this is going to lead us to some of
these big ethical issues
everybody get to do mental cultivation
if somebody hasn't had it do they know
that they need it
i think it's not necessarily a matter of
knowing that you need it rather than the
natural thing that you do
maybe you don't do it as well unless
you're aware of it but yeah
well
we do have something like an instinct in
us to drive us to want to to learn about
things but it's very easily diverted
um
i mean a lot of lives
haven't had much mental cultivation
a lot of them haven't had much
experience either
do you think that maybe
that's something that we ought to be
giving to people
that's really what's needed for the good
life
for genuine happiness
do we have a duty to make that available
to people
that was that mill was was arguing that
it was he was arguing at a time where he
says
you know
most people are not experiencing this
most people don't even have the chance
to experience this
he was writing at the height of the
industrial revolution
when a lot of people were
working
very very long days for very very low
wages
and living
pretty short lives
and there wasn't a public school system
and
public schools in england actually mean
private schools which is kind of a weird
thing
what was it like over here it was
pretty similar over here
i know my my grandparents
my grandmother went to high school
because all the girls got to go to high
school my grandpa only well one grandpa
got to sixth grade
the other one got to second grade
and then they started working
do you think they got to
do all you know a lot of mental
cultivation
if they did it was on the side actually
both of them did because they sought it
out
and then they had a lot of interesting
experiences
but do we have a duty to provide this to
people
well let me put it to a different way
all of you went to
middle school elementary school high
school
um
did you get out of it what you what you
wanted to get out of it besides you
don't pay for saying you
yeah i think i don't know we grew up
giving the opportunity but we're to do
to get our pleasures and
yeah you know
and everything i just think that a lot
of people don't take advantage of the
opportunity but we developed the
experience and i think that's just
because i i'm guilty of that myself
not a lot of people push them in the
direction like oh you know you should
really try getting really involved with
this you might like it
yeah i think i think that you're right
that
when we offer opportunities to people
especially in this society where we take
so many things for granted
most people don't rise to the to the
challenge
i'm pleasant i'm very pleasantly
experienced
very
pleasantly surprised excuse me i'm
teaching here at marist by how many
students actually do respond to that
sort of thing compared to other places
that
i've taught
but yeah i think that you're right that
a lot of
people when you offer them
a chance to engage in mental cultivation
and experience some of the higher
pleasures they they they don't do it
they take it for granted i'm going to
read the cliff notes instead of reading
the book
i'm not going to struggle with this sort
of stuff
um
you're right but that doesn't
necessarily go against whether we ought
to be providing people with that
that's something to think about mill
thinks there's something like a duty to
to education
to improving society so that everybody
has the chance to
experience these things
we often take what we have
very much
so like if you look at like the u.s
generally everybody's
most people are allowed to go to high
school
when i graduate a lot of people dropped
out just because
for no reason other than they didn't
feel like going
so i mean yeah it's like a line that you
have to draw between
you know keep giving them more and more
opportunities or
allowing them to take advantage of the
opportunities that they
have in front of them
yeah you know where it really arises
as an issue
and i think utilitarians would be um
receptive to this is how much we're
gonna
how much
we're going to pay for that sort of
thing
um
it's interesting because some of the
worst school systems in the united
states are some of the ones that they
throw the most money at
like the dc public schools you know they
spend a lot of money per student
their
graduation rate is very low
chicago public schools
you know overall graduation rates pretty
well
you can also not spend very much money
and also have a very low graduation
graduation rate like where my children
live in indiana
there are two schools and the last
graduation rates that i looked at for
them because there's only two high
schools in the county one was 75 the
other one was 66
which is not very good um
and you know people dropping out clearly
they're not they're not doing that and
you could actually get through high
school pretty easily and not engage in
much mental cultivation just sort of
show up and
do the right thing and there are some
schools where there's not going to be
any mental cultivation taking place
anyway because you know students are
packed in 32 of the room and there's no
discipline
and you can't get anything done
i think no would say we ought to try to
change that
but you're right cost is one of the
factors that we have to look at because
every time you say taxing people you're
taking away one of the means to
budget right
that's a good segue into talking about
duty and virtue and wealth so if we know
that for utilitarians pleasure
is the
be-all and end-all the final good
and we talked about all these other
things before like you know well
right if somebody desires wealth for its
own end
we often say well they've got their
priorities screwed up right
somebody who's a miser they won't they
won't spend any money
even though it would bring them some
pleasure
they won't spend it on any better things
we would say why do you want all that
money
what's all that money for
and if we were aristotle we would put
virtue like over here and say well you
know if you're virtuous you'll get
pleasure from that
but virtue is something better than
pleasure
mill will actually place virtue
and duty and things like that sort of on
the way
and he says
so here's some you know rival
conceptions of of the good virtue is the
good or doing duty as the good and
oftentimes they require you to go
against pleasure you know if you want to
become a
just person every once in a while you
don't take the last piece of pie because
you already had some and you let
somebody else happen right so you forgot
some pleasures
if you want to be a temperate person you
don't eat just as much as you'd like to
you maybe eat a little bit less
and you don't go out on you know a
12-pack drinking jag every every other
night that wouldn't be temperate right
although it could be
pleasant for a while
well
one of the things that mill notices
is that
duty or virtue or wealth or power
or any of these other goods that we've
been talking about think about career
family
a utility the utilitarian would say why
do we actually want these things
well originally we found them pleasant
or they were a means to something
pleasant and if you do this often enough
through the force of
habits
all of these things start to get tied up
together
and
let's take virtue for an example
how do people actually become virtuous
remember back to your aristotle
if you want to make somebody courageous
what do you have to do
they have to
keep doing the
something courageous over and over again
to develop the habit of yeah so
habits involved
how do you know when they've actually
become
courageous does anyone remember that
from aristotle
when they
then you say when they have the
opportunity
and they're challenged to a certain
extent and they either and then they
make like a big decision whether it be
courageous or not yeah they so it
involves deliberate choice
it becomes something like second nature
something you they don't have to think
about you know
before they they actually start doing it
um there's another thing aristotle says
you may have missed it and i didn't
actually focus on the class aristotle
says one way that you can tell that
somebody is virtuous
is they take pleasure in virtuous
actions
so the courageous person when you're
first starting out um
doing things that require courage
um
it's scary and that's a feeling right
that's an emotion but it's also in a way
kind of painful
and you don't really want to do it but
you have to make yourself do it
and then think about public speaking how
many of you do any of you still have a
fear of public speaking
uh i you know i don't have it now
but i but i used to know when i first
started teaching
um
i would you know kind of get the shapes
and stuff like that
um and you do it often enough and then
after a while it goes away how many of
you had a fear of public speaking at one
time you know you oh so quite a few of
you
how did it go away you actually did some
public speaking right
either that or you know
you
somebody gave you a drug and then you
didn't you didn't feel scared or
something like that there's ways around
it but those won't those won't change
your character will they those won't
change your makeup
and after a while
if you keep on doing it
you'll actually come to enjoy
that sort of courageous action
and then you can transfer it to other
things so public speaking wasn't so bad
maybe cliff diagon won't be so bad
although you know that could be
foolhardy too right
maybe standing up to a bully won't be so
bad
maybe standing up in a public forum for
something that i believe in
uh when we're in a highly contested
election
and people could say terrible things
about me
maybe that won't be so bad so you sort
of ratchet it up right maybe going in
front of the boss
at the company that you work at and
saying i think that the company is on
the wrong track
here's why i think so
maybe that won't be terrifying
maybe that won't be painful
maybe after you do it you'll feel a
sense of accomplishment that's the case
that becomes the habit and then pretty
soon
you become
the kind of person who behaves
virtuously because you actually enjoy
that
mill thinks that
if utilitarianism if utilitarianism is
going to work
for individuals and for society we
actually need these sort of things
to become
habits
habits that involve
getting pleasure
and then we'll choose to do the right
thing
because we actually enjoy it
we won't actually think about do i enjoy
this
we'll just sort of start doing it again
second nature
um
let's go on and think about some issues
now so
one of the things that students
often like to
sink their teeth into are these these
big issues right
we just talked about one education do we
have a duty to
provide a system of education not not
just you know learning you know the
three r's reading writing arithmetic or
computer skills
or vocational training or things like
that but actually teaching people what
is pleasant and what is painful and what
are the higher levels of pleasure do we
introduce them to great books do we
introduce them to great music where are
we going to cut our programs and cut
music programs cut athletic programs as
well
are we going to introduce them
and deepen their appreciation of these
things and allow them to compare them to
each other or are we just going to say
ah that will happen in college
which you know by that point probably
they're not that receptive that's an
issue
another big issue is hunger
and
with this one we're not going to think
in terms of qualitative utilitarianism
we'll think just in terms of
quantitative utilitarianism
right now the world is actually in many
respects
better than it was 40 years ago
because there's about 7 billion people
in the world
so
and
the way it sort of splits up
if you think about people's quality of
life
um
roughly about one billion maybe a little
bit less have it
really good
as a matter of fact
in the western world which means in the
united states canada
europe japan we actually have a problem
with obesity
we have people who
um
when it comes to food and hunger
they're so far away from food and hunger
that they they eat more than they need
routinely for years and years and years
and diet often you know like diabetes or
heart disease or things like that
over at the other extreme
where you have extreme poverty
they find that hard to understand
i mean these are the people who are
living on just rice
and then there's the
rest of the world where things are
you know not so good
but they're still
vulnerable
and you know we're not at the point
we've been you know here for about maybe
15 years where
for this group of people they're still
living in the third world they're still
living in conditions that are not so hot
but things are sort of on the upswing
global capitalism has not been bad to
everybody it's offered a lot of
opportunities the jobs that have been
outsourced for example from the united
states they went somewhere else most
people
are getting paid less but they're
they're earning more than they were
before and they're able to put more food
on the table and you know
improve their quality of life
india and china are great examples of
this
there is a lot of terrible poverty in
parts of china
but there's a lot of parts of china
where things aren't so bad so there's
you know there's actually a fairly rich
section as well usually tied up with the
party
but this this group are still vulnerable
i mean all it takes is a couple bad
harvests and they are over here
right
whereas couple bed harvests and we're
not going to be really good will be
pretty good
because we have a lot of things stored
up
and
you know we have i mean
look at me
you know what it was fat fat is stored
energy
um if i you know got thrown into some
sort of famine situation my body could
actually use the fat reserves in my body
and draw on those i wouldn't starve to
death right away
somebody over here they're at risk of
starving all the time
so that's a situation that we're at
now let's think about this as
utilitarians utilitarians have actually
written a lot about this
why is why are things like this
is this just a fact of life is this just
the way it has to be
we know we actually have enough food to
feed everybody
america probably by itself
produces enough food
to feed most of the world
so
what would a utilitarian say
think about in terms of pain and
pleasure being hungry what's that like
painful yeah
um
what happens when you're hungry besides
feeling hunger pains
can you can you get things done
can you concentrate
at a certain point your
like
mental abilities start to degrade yeah
that's why we want kids to eat some of
the school lunch programs we want them
to eat before they come to school and a
lot of parents you know either
don't know the means or
don't have the
discipline to feed their kids before
they come to school so we feed them so
that the kids can actually pay attention
in school you know if you go to third
world schools
some of which are actually in this area
you'll hear kids talk about i didn't eat
for two days and i'm having trouble you
know following my lessons
and
that's a lot of misery and even this is
you know
could could things be better for them
if resources were more
equitably shared
would they have more pleasure
now let's say we're at all you know
chip in
um involuntarily let's say our
government's all decided okay we're
gonna we're gonna start working on these
problems we're not just gonna leave with
the food companies
we're going to impose a
save the third world tax
on everybody
that would be unpleasant right
you don't make nobody feels that they
make enough money right
and you know money is a means to
happiness
so if they take away some of your money
they're taking away some of your
happiness right
but overall would it be
better you have a more equitable system
of food distribution
just look at the numbers right if you're
a utilitarian you care about numbers
5 billion over here 1 billion over here
6 out weighs one doesn't it
it does but to extend it would be good
to start off that way yeah but you need
to have something in place where
the
third third world country can do it
themselves otherwise you're just ah yeah
they're throwing
resources at it and you're not really
getting
you know the other aspect of the
pleasure which is being able to
reproduce
you know
being able to pleasure yourself
i think you're right um
that could be a secondary
issue to sort of address after dealing
with the uh
the first issue should there be a more
equitable distribution then there would
be a question you know if we say yes
then we have to ask a lot of other
questions like well precisely how do you
want to do this and there'd be different
ways to do it some of which would maybe
produce more pain
when you make people dependent
you're right
there's a certain pain that comes with
being constantly dependent
not everybody who benefits from say
welfare systems
looks at that as getting over
or just their rights some of them find
that very humiliating
you know people have to go on food
stamps for example
some people look at that as just ah
that's just the right and that's what
everybody does other people it kills
them to do that and that would be a type
of type of pain
so you're right you know fostering
independence maybe instead of just you
know
dealing out massive amounts of grain we
would do this money you guys are
familiar with micro lending
any of you guys heard of that what's
microlight yeah it's like getting on
small loans to
um maybe like a lot of times they use
like women in this example they have
like small companies that do like
selling or something
yeah
you give out these loans and they're
they're loans that for us would be like
nothing i mean how many of us think much
of dropping 25 bucks at a restaurant
i mean that's not a bad it's for two
people that's that's a pretty cheap meal
for us but that could actually get
somebody's entire livelihood going you
could buy them a couple goats you know
you can buy them machinery because
things are so cheap in the
third world and then you're
giving them that independence and
allowing them to become
producers over here over here maybe that
would produce more pleasure maybe doing
micro lending would be better than just
doling out one gigantic check to
everybody right
we're giving everybody a big bag of
flour
but there we're talking about the means
to implement it there's the so there's
the how do you implement it how do you
actually do it and then there's the
bigger issue of should we actually do
that and utilitarians would say when it
comes to world hunger
those who actually have the means that
we do ought to be doing things to
alleviate it and actually we are to some
extent aren't we
the united states gives a lot of aid and
we're also people
who do an incredible amount of volunteer
and charity work
charity organizations and other
non-government organizations do massive
amounts
components
so that's one thing you can look at from
the utilitarian perspective
another issue
is punishment
and i don't mean like parents punishing
child children or anything like that
but same criminal justice somebody
commits a crime
should we punish them and mill actually
talks specifically about this in
uh
that treatise utilitarianism
and the utilitarians were very
instrumental in changing
the nature of
punishment and judicial judicial system
to
look at things in a bit of a different
way
if you're a utilitarian let's think
about what what is what is punishment
what happens when you punish somebody
or what are some examples of punishment
send them to jail okay so prison
that's one big thing that we do
what else find them yeah
monetary
fines
sometimes you kill them right it's
pretty rare these days
in most states
sometimes sending the people to prison
depending on the circumstances is kind
of like this death sentence because
they'll get killed by somebody inside
you know like when they send uh
dahmer or gagging into prison sooner or
later somebody will get them
but
that's sort of an unintended consequence
um any other ways we punish people yeah
yeah
some people find that to be
very humiliating
community
service
okay
so
there could be pledges in these
but are there usually pleasures of these
does anybody i mean some people actually
you know
don't have to be sentenced and they say
i want to do some community service
that's that's a good thing but i don't
think a lot of people get sentenced to
community service hear that and they're
like
oh yay
unless they're they're happy they're not
say going to prison
um
now they're they're happier about that
right oh i should have prison or
jail
jail's different than
short term
versus television
are there pains involved with these
yeah these are these are painful things
that's why we do them
that's why we impose them take away
somebody's liberty and put them in a
place that is not very pleasant to be in
that's
a pain
we also may
give other people pleasure by doing that
or we may prevent them from being in
pain if we take a dangerous criminal off
the street we put him or her in prison
we're preventing future pain from other
people right but they might rob or kill
or rape or do whatever to community
service
maybe that's providing some other people
some pleasure
you know
even if it's just stuff like picking up
trash it makes things look nicer
but it's unpleasant for the person
experiencing it right
um capital punishment
no no treat for anybody involved the
ways in which we do it are not uh
remotely close to as painful as the way
they used to be but they're still
painful right and
executions are not
a
joyous occasion for anybody
fines fines you know you take away
somebody's money that's that's painful
right
or is it pleasurable
anybody like
when you get a speeding ticket anybody
say oh great 80 bucks i couldn't wait to
spend this on
on
what county are in here dutchess county
on dutchess county
i'm so glad my tax my tax dollars i'm so
glad my fine dollars are going to be put
to work fixing the roads is that how we
actually behave no we see that as a bad
thing so these are all
considered by themselves
bad things right because they're painful
why do we oppose them the utilitarian on
the face of it would say it's a bad
thing
shouldn't do it to anybody then
why do we punch yeah like to keep you
from doing something worse exactly
very good
that's a good way to put the lesser of
two evils
we could set up two alternatives where
say
a dangerous criminal is allowed to be on
the street they commit more crimes
they're committing more
bad things they're causing other people
greater pain
it is causing them pain to put them in
prison actually it may actually be
inflicting pain on other prisoners
dude have to be in a cell next to this
guy
but the overall balance
of pleasures and pains
is better you you're not actually
picking the best thing you're picking
the lesser of two evils
punishment always involves some some
evil
but it's the lesser of two evils and a
utilitarian would say you can only do it
for a few purposes you can do it to
actually
keep people off the street you know
because they're dangerous and you're
going to prevent that or to deter other
people
from committing those crimes and now
think about deterrence for a minute
think about the other reasons why we
punish people sometimes we punish people
because we're mad at them right
we want to see them paid
think now not not just about you know
judicial punishment
think about when when your friend treats
you badly and you're not going to talk
to them
or you're going to call them a name
or you're not going to show up for
something you're not going to give them
a ride home or something like that
you're going to punish them and are you
punishing them only because you're
concerned about their future behavior no
you're punishing them for something they
did in the past right
the utilitarian doesn't look at the past
the utilitarian looks just at the
present and the future
so if the future good
is not going to outweigh
the badness of punishment a utilitarian
would say don't do that so that would
rule out certain kinds of punishment
wouldn't it
a utilitarian probably would not be for
torturing people to death
which they do in some places
or some you know some cultures do that
if you think about
criminal organizations
when they kill people they often do it
in very gruesome ways
why do they do that
well partly to
you know
deter other people from doing it but
they inflict these horrible
things on people which i don't even talk
about because
they may turn your stomachs
but you know you can look into the
literature on them
so a utilitarian is going to say
you can have punishment but it has to be
within
certain constraints
there have to be certain limits
and it has to be done for a certain
purpose for the purpose of
protecting other people and deterring
future man behavior
if you're doing it just for revenge a
utilitarian would say that's not a good
moment to do it
um
lastly let's think about this one's a
more difficult one
so this is a very contentious issue
how would a utility a utilitarian
somebody still strip over that word
how would they approach the question of
abortion when we talk about abortion we
we can mean
a couple different things we could mean
should abortion be legal in a society
that's what often what people mean or we
could mean something like an individual
case if a person has a pregnancy and
they
don't want to raise the child for one
reason or another
is it is it right or wrong for them to
abort the
pregnancy
which would you like to look at
pick either one
because they because they are
not exactly the same issue should it be
legal
a matter of public policy or do you want
to look at a new sort of like individual
case
with the individual kids okay so let's
think about this in terms of the
individual
um
who's affected we have
a utilitarian we look at pleasures and
pains
guaranteed there's a
mother right
and then
this is where it gets sticky how do we
label
the next person involved we say child we
say baby do we say fetus do we say
embryo
because each one of these seems to carry
some some moral weight with it
let's let's try to take the most neutral
term we'll say fetus right
anybody else involved
who that would feel pleasure or pain
potentially
do you think
yeah will you go to the extended family
okay very good um
anybody else who could be potentially
yeah the father
often gets
left out of these decisions sometimes in
part because why you know
why in many cases do women find
themselves in conditions
where they're
considering having an abortion
because the birth father
vacated the premises
after after they found out that somebody
got pregnant and there's other cases too
like rape right somebody gets
gets raped and then
there's you know a lot of trauma there
with the rape and maybe the child would
be a reminder of that
um you've all heard these arguments one
way or the other right
so let's think about this in utilitarian
terms
the father and the extended family
they're potentially affected right
they can have pains and pleasures
but it is potential right maybe the
father doesn't know about what's going
on
maybe the extended family never finds
out because the woman who has the
abortion uh keeps it a secret or maybe
only part of the extended family finds
out you know
the brother of the woman takes her to
have the abortion nobody says anything
about it at that point
so their pains and pleasures are
probably going to weigh less in the
balance so let's let's just focus on
these two then
let's think about the mother
what are the potential
pains
involved
birth
is usually pretty painful a few women do
experience it you know just going you
know like like clockwork that's not
usually the case
birth is painful
um what else
abortion's painful too
operational
moral pain like to actually have the
abortion and they
feel uh
guilty about married
many many women have
psychological
problems after after having an abortion
why might
why might one then actually
the view is that the mother is going to
have a lower quality of life
she's going to be a single mother
usually they're very young you know
and
they're usually this this pertains to
the the child as well
the fetus comes to term
they're going to be born into poverty
they're not going to be offered
opportunities their life is not going to
be very good
um versus
ending it right away with a bit of a
little bit of pain fetuses do feel pain
all right we know this from seeing them
ride and stuff
the fact that their nervous systems are
developing but it's over very quickly
isn't it
in general sometimes we've watched
the utilitarians would most likely
be for abortion if
the mother
wants to do it
because a lot of the psychological pain
comes about thinking that it's wrong and
that's precisely what's being determined
at this point kant would say something
completely different we're going to look
at kant
next
the other thing to think about
i'm going to put this into the problem
there are some women who have abortions
and then go on to have kids and they say
things along the lines of well if i
if i didn't abort the first kid
or
worth the first fetus then my later
children wouldn't have it as good as
they do a utilitarian would actually be
receptive to that argument because they
look at everything in terms of
an aggregate of individual pains of
pleasure
and a utilitarian probably would be
receptive to the idea of a life
whose quality is so low that it that it
would it would be worse than
than not living
compt again is not going to see things
this way thomas aquinas wouldn't see
things this way but that is where
utilitarianism would go on this so i'll
see all of you
thursday